willkommen bei einem neuen video
ja es ist gerade ein uhr morgens und ich
habe irgendwie gerade total bock ein
video zu drehen
jetzt stellt sich nur die frage was
mache ich und da ich keinen bock haben
jetzt irgendein thema rauszusuchen und
dazu noch ein skript zu schreiben habe
ich mir gedacht kommen versucht doch
einfach mal was anderes du hast jetzt
weit auch schon wieder deine 2000 abos
erreicht und ja ich habe mir da so was
cooles überlegt ich hoffe cool ist auf
jeden fall ist ja zurzeit dieses spiel
blackbird total in und das kam ich jetzt
gleich mal aus meinem handy heraus
beziehungsweise nicht ob das jetzt eine
wunde und zwar habe ich mir da so
gedacht ich spiele einfach mal drei
runden in der ersten runde ist es mein
ziel 10 früheren darüber zu durchfliegen
in der zweiten runde ist mein ziel 20
hören und in der dritten runde ist mein
ziel 40 hören
und jetzt mal als beispiel wenn ich in
durchgang eins nur fünf von diesen zehn
rühren schaffe dann muss ich so eine
kleine bestrafung wenn ich es jetzt mal
machen und zwar habe ich mir hier
verschiedene sachen hingestellt einmal
ist dass hier gurken wasser ich weiß
nicht ob man das so gut erkennen kann
auf jeden fall sind diese ekligen auf
jeden fall hat sich das extrem das hier
ist so ein komischer weise wie es nennt
soll das milch drin vor anker ketchup
und senf stimmt auch sehr lecker und
dann hier noch mal nimmt mit einem
löffel das heißt einfach ein löffel sind
also wenn ich jetzt gleich in dem ersten
durchgang nur fünf von zehn versuchen
schaffte
darf ich mir eine von diesen drei sachen
erhalt rausnehmen oder aussuchen und
diese bestrafung dampf machen auf jeden
fall
ich will gar nicht lange lagern ich will
sagen wir fangen jetzt einfach direkt
ja und dann würde ich mal sagen
durchgang eins startet jetzt mein ziel
ist es halt einfach zehn rühren zu
durchfliegen und im jahr auf die plätze
fertig los
fängt ja schon gut also ich habe jetzt
gerade nur 5 von 10 punkten erreicht das
heißt ich suche mir jetzt eine von
diesen drei sachen aus und ich will
sagen fang argument hier mit mit diesen
tipps links auf jeden fall irgendwie
machen das ja voll viele und die sterben
dabei fast aber ich mag zum voll und ich
kann mir gar nicht vorstellen dass es so
eigentlich ist jetzt tun
ich sag jetzt mal ist der floh das müsse
ein dafür sein
ich habe jetzt mal eine schüssel und
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
mit
das ist aber überhaupt nicht ja und
jetzt befinden wir uns hier in durchgang
zwei und jetzt ist das tier hat einfach
20 jahren ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen
gedreht da bin ich besser zocken an
auf die plätze fertig los
ja also die 20
was mache ich jetzt so höre die 20
röhren habe jetzt gerade geschafft und
jetzt muss ich noch mal versuchen 40 zu
schaffen ist relativ schwer würde ich
mal sagen aber man kann es ja mal
versuchen und ihr euch drews war die
kamera wieder so schön nach hier unten
so und seht ihr das gut bestimmt auf die
plätze fertig los
manchmal drückt man irgendwie
automatisch noch mal drauf
ja also mit dem 14
mit den jetzt auch nichts und jetzt auch
noch schön ist von diesen sachen
aussehen und ich kann guten was wirklich
überhaupt den klassischen plastikdosen
ich habe auch meine cycle kanal muss ich
schon mal da bin ich habe jetzt mein
halbes glas voll mal gucken ob ich das
schaffen will auf diesen diesen hilft
ihr keinen bock auf die plätze
schmeckt so widerlich
bestimmt die ganze nacht geschmack in
meinem mund
na ja wir sollten das wasser doch leider
schon wieder mit diesem kleinen
beziehungsweise für mich schrecklich im
video
nein spaß irgendwie fand ich auch ganz
witzig war mal was anderes und letzte
frage an euch wollt ihr sowas auch mal
öfter sehen beziehungsweise sogar diese
flat world challenge wollt ihr die
nochmal sehen dann vielleicht mit dem
kumpel schreibt sie doch einfach mal
rein in die kommentare oder gebt einfach
den daumen hoch dann weiß ich ja dass es
euch gefallen hat und dass ihr das
nochmal sehen wollte ansonsten wenn ihr
nicht mehr verpassen wollt dann
abonniert einfach den kanal und die
heute und hier unten rechts geht jetzt
weiter mit einem netz video das war so
ein tag der hieß intime fragen dort habe
ich so ein paar intime fragen
beantwortet also checkt es auf jeden
fall mal ab und hier unten links gibt es
auch einen tag beziehungsweise fast
einen tag oder was heißt fast es ist ein
tag und zwar girlfriend tag mit meiner
freundin könnt ihr auch mal
vorbeischauen
ansonsten hoffen natürlich ihr lest auch
mal kräftig die video beschreibung und
guckt mal auf instagram vorbei oder so
und ich sage dir eine schau